there's a foster couple outside mr.
badson I can take care of myself give
these people a chance cuz that's what
they're giving you
Billy is a foster kid he's been in and
out of foster homes this is Billy Batson
he's a really good kid who wants the
best who sticks up for the other kids
hey man sorry about that hand because he
is pure of hearts baby backs these
transports of this wizard I choose you
as champion who and douse him with this
power of Shazam Shazam see he has this
power of just saying one word and
turning into a superhero he goes to see
his friend Freddy you're the only person
I know that knows anything about this
Cape Crusader stuff what are your
superpowers super powers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing
Freddy is superhero fanatic fishin we
find out that Billy is a superhero is
like I know exactly what to do Freddy's
like okay we have to test your abilities
and of course they're gonna film it okay
why are you talking I feel like any good
who gains a power of being and it's all
thinking like you shouldn't do things
that only adults can do duh I'd like to
purchase some of your finest beer please
that's his actual phone
it's wish-fulfillment it doesn't want to
be a superhero I'm still waiting Shazam
is one of very few superhero characters
it is genuinely stoked to be a super
yo-yo pun charge your phone charged help
more often than not you've got a
character who is but grudgingly pulled
into this is everybody needs them in the
Lego I have to see the world again Billy
Batson his Stoke you're like a bad guy
right I just get to show up on set and
be like forget to do this I get to fly
around fight bad guys you're dead
[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself
when you're 18 give these people a
chance because that's what they're
giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're just able to
foster kid you've got it all Vince you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz heroes fly well you
need your fake family to stand up for
you hey man sorry about that
Billy Batson I choose you
ask a peon
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir sure Sam wait for you okay Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight
this is crazy right what are your
superpowers super powers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing super
straight just can you fly if I quit your
mail okay why are you sucking your
co-stars your phone charged like a bad
guy right
you have full immunity from your dead
sorry about your window welcome for not
getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero do your
backside
I choose you say my name so my powers
will become yours
[Music]
[Music]
I'd like to purchase some of your finest
beer please Sam oler yes if you have a
location they're gonna cliff on your
castle ask type thing you're looking
some water some water splashing on rocks
and stuff then we will take that
experience it in IMAX
[Music]